the Victoria Falls the biggest curtain
of falling water in the world but not
right now and maybe no longer the
waterfall which divides Zambia and
Zimbabwe has fallen to its lowest level
in about 25 years
it often dries up in sections on the
Zambian side but this is much worse than
normal it's a fraction and the huge
walls of rock should be covered with
cascading water we took to the air in a
microlight to better see the dramatic
change exacerbated by a long drought and
a delayed rainy season there's no doubt
it's still one of the most spectacular
visual feasts you'll ever see but it
seems to be disappearing
[Music]
impact is dramatically started from this
angle the world largest Falls now down
to a triple in places
we're not careful we're gonna lose this
site entirely
the drop in water levels has had a
drastic effect creating islands and the
Zambezi which weren't there before
Zambia is heavily dependent on
hydropower but the rivers flow has
dwindled to a third of last year's
causing power cuts hitting businesses
and wildlife these hippos are standing
on the riverbed slap bang in the centre
of one of Africa's mightiest rivers
some past years the hippo they were not
found like on the meat of the river but
now this year because of our the drought
on the river and which is not good sign
the lack of water is threatening much
more than Zambia's wildlife which
attracts hundreds of thousands of
tourists every year Zambians are
desperate forced to dig deeper and
deeper to find water the cattle rush for
whatever is doled out they are showing
visible signs of months of little food
their owners will drink water from the
same source and cook and bathe and clean
with it the country's president blames
all this on climate change and had to
dig at the doubters which include the US
president when he spoke exclusively to
sky a serious problem
and a surprise when people three realize
it and say it's not really probably
they're living in a different world but
this world we live in Zambia we are
feeling the effects of climate change
very obviously and the impacting on
everyone it's called
mounts atonia the smoke that thunders
but without some intervention quickly
the president's warning some of the
continents natural riches could be lost
forever
Alex Crawford Sky News at Victoria Falls
in Zambia